Hi. Listen, apparently, er,
Paul's written the script this week.
There's a script?
Well, er, apparently he feels
we're not really setting the right tone.
-Right.
-Er, here.
-"Hi, I'm Sandra Thompson."
-"And I'm Neil Folding."
Wow, this is terrible.
-Er, let's get on, Sandra.
-It's Sandi.
-Whatever. Action!
-[Sandi] Er...
[both] Welcome to Paul Hollywood's
Great British Baking Show.
Starring Paul Hollywood.
-Perfect. Cut.
-[Sandi] Wow. You coming to the tent?
[Noel] No, I gotta do
some more filming with Paul.
Apparently he's cast me
in some sort of sexual thriller.
[Sandi] Doesn't surprise me.
[Paul] Neil, make mine white
with one, please.
[both chuckle]
-[Sandi] Now...
-Right, meringue.
...we go back in time
to the Roaring Twenties...
You've managed to make
these flapper girls look quite flirty.
...where the bakers
have old-fashioned fear.
-Michael, you okay?
-I'm freaking out.
Keep doing the smiley face.
That's disgusting.
As the pressure builds...
If Priya doesn't have
a really strong Showstopper,
Priya may not be here next week.
Slide, slide, my pretties, slide.
...to a period drama in the tent.
[clattering]
Oh, no. She's dropped her tart.
[theme music playing]
[indistinct conversations]
I can't believe I'm still here,
to be honest.
I thought I was a goner last week.
I actually thought it was as easy as
turn up for a weekend
to bake in a tent
and going home to normal life.
It's not like that. It's tough.
[David] Last week,
we let the judges down a bit.
This week, we're gonna show them
why we're all here.
Hello, bakers. Welcome back to the tent.
Today, we are going back
to the Roaring Twenties.
The time famous for jazz, the Charleston,
flapper girls...
Er, the 1928 Kellogg-Briand Pact.
Fantastic international peace treaty--
-[Noel] Sandi.
-Sorry. Yes, baking.
Er, 1920s! Custard pies,
very popular during that decade.
So, for your Signature Challenge,
the judges would like you to make
four individual,
highly decorative custard pies.
Your pie should be open-topped,
and the custard should set
during baking.
You have two-and-a-half hours.
-On your marks...
-Get set...
Bake.
[Noel] Custard pies were
a slapstick staple in the 1920s.
Hopefully there's no, er, custard pies
being thrown around today.
I don't think I'll throw this
in anyone's face.
Unless I get bad comments.
I might just, like... [blows raspberry]
Shove it in Paul's face.
Don't tell him I said that.
[Noel] Unlike the stunt pies
in the silent movies,
which were made using thick, heavy pastry,
the bakers will be making
a delicate shortcrust.
The shortcrust pastry,
you want it to melt in the mouth,
and that's the critical thing.
Overwork, it makes it too rubbery.
So the best thing to do with the pastry
is just bring it together,
chill it down.
[David] Now it goes to rest.
I want to see a beautifully formed
custard pie, silky-smooth,
but it must contain a theme of the 1920s.
It's a lovely period to be thinking about,
because you think of Art Deco,
flapper girls, so we want
the decoration to reflect that.
[Sandi] While the pastry
is given time to rest,
-there's no respite for the bakers.
-Sorry, darling.
Right, orange curd.
[Sandi] If they are to achieve
the highly decorative finish
Paul and Prue are expecting,
every second counts.
This mousse needs to set in the freezer.
And the pastry is just resting
in the fridge, chilling,
so I can do this while I have the time.
I know they're gonna say I'm nuts,
but, hey, I already have that reputation.
Might as well live up to it.
-Helena.
-Hey. Good morning.
Helena, I'm really looking forward
to your custard pies
-'cause they're bound to be weird.
-That's fantastic.
They are. [chuckles]
They are decorated
with an ancient Greek sea creature
-coming out of the--
-Like a Gorgon.
Yeah. Originally, I had them
in the shape of lemons,
and then I thought, "It's just not me.
I'm going with a monster."
[Noel] Helena's mythical sea creature
will be emerging
from a bed of meringue sea foam,
standing guard over
her lavender and lemon custard pies.
Is this, erm, remotely 1920s,
do you think?
Yeah.
-I think it sounds fantastic.
-Yeah, lovely.
[chuckles]
[Noel] Helena is not the only baker
drawing inspiration
from 1920s pop culture.
I looked up that the drink Kool-Aid.
was founded in America during the '20s,
and one of the original flavours
was lemon and lime.
Hence I'm doing
lemon and lime custard tarts.
And then one of the other
original flavours was raspberry,
so there's gonna be little raspberry
curd hemispheres at the top.
They will hopefully be mirror-glazed
yellow and green, 'cause lemon and lime.
'Tis the plan.
[Sandi] In addition
to his ambitious domes,
Henry will be decorating
his lemon and lime custard pies
with candied lemon slices,
fresh raspberries,
and delicately piped Italian meringue.
[Henry] I'm gonna stick to the schedule
and all will be well.
That is... The best part of this challenge
is doing that.
[Noel] Also hoping to wow the judges
with their impressive domes is Rosie.
-[Sandi] What is the smell we're getting?
-[Rosie] Erm, this is elderflower jelly.
Oh, it's lovely.
[Rosie] There's gonna be
little hemispheres of jelly,
and then I'm injecting a few different
colours into them just to make flowers.
'Cause you're a vet,
have you brought the needles from--
I have brought them in from work.
They are horse vaccine syringes.
But they are new.
-Okay, good.
-[Rosie] They are brand-new.
Finally, we're getting you
some horse vaccine.
-Phew.
-[all chuckle]
[Noel] Rosie's elderflower domes
will inject a touch of 1920s glamour
to her blackberry and custard pies.
[Rosie] Now I need to just
not drop these everywhere.
[Sandi] While Rosie creates
flowers in jelly form,
Michelle has allowed Mother Nature
to lend a helping hand.
You made a small garden--
-[Michelle] Do you know what? I love--
-[Noel] This is what?
Flowers! I love 'em,
I grow them in the garden.
[Sandi] With edible flowers
on a brûléed top
above a blueberry compote
and white chocolate custard,
today Michelle's hoping
to come up smelling of roses.
Do you think it was quite hard last week?
Very hard last week.
It was brutal, wasn't it?
Paul was a savage.
-And I was just--
-He is a savage, though.
-[Michelle] Really?
-[Noel] Yeah. He's part wolf.
Er, what am I doing? Getting the pastry.
[Sandi] Once the pastry
is sufficiently chilled,
it can be rolled out,
ready for blind baking.
You want chilled pastry,
but you also want to be able to roll it.
Argh! This is so hard.
[Sandi] If the bakers roll
their chilled dough too thin,
it runs the risk of breakage.
[David] Once this is baked,
a tiny bit of pressure
will just crumble it or snap it.
And, yeah, I'm pretty clumsy.
[Sandi] However,
if their pie cases are too thick,
there won't be enough room to hold
the required amount of custard.
Shortcrust definitely
isn't a favourite of mine.
Always my biggest nemesis.
Oh. Hi.
Probably shouldn't be saying that
in such close proximity to the judges.
[Noel] Should Steph manage
to conquer her fears,
her sweet, rich shortcrust
will surround her zesty custard,
which will be flavoured
with lemon, lime and orange.
I'm trying to take, erm,
the classic tarte au citron,
and add a bit more zest.
So they are going in at 180 degrees
for 15 minutes.
Going in for about 12 minutes.
[Sandi] Not enough time in the oven
during the blind bake,
and the pastry will be raw.
You need to bake it
more than you perhaps would
were you putting
not a soggy filling in it.
-[Sandi] Too much time...
-Twenty minutes.
[Sandi] ...and when they go back in
filled with custard,
the cases will overbake.
[David] You only want a tiny bit
of colour because they're so delicate.
What could go wrong? Everything.
-What's the theme again today?
-Can't remember.
Bakers, you are halfway through.
[Michael] I'm making the custard now.
This is actually really hard.
I've not got a very long time
to do all of this stuff.
Need one more egg.
I've got eggs. I've got eggs.
[Noel] A basic custard is made up of
egg yolk, sugar, cream and vanilla,
but the judges will be expecting
the bakers to pimp up their pies.
It has got some orange extract
just to give it an extra orange kick.
You will taste the orange in this.
[Noel] Alice will be hoping her
orange-infused custard will pack a punch,
alongside a rich, chocolatey pastry.
How do you know
when your custard's baked in the oven?
So, it should be kind of just set with
a little bit of a wobble in the middle.
"Just set with a bit of a wobble
in the middle." Sounds like my physique.
-Pretty nice.
-[chuckles]
I'm making a blackberry custard,
so, yeah, mine is dark purple.
Why not?
I've just added, erm, purple
food colouring, because it's lavender.
And I'm doing something
completely different.
[Sandi] Not everyone is being
so adventurous.
[David] I'm actually doing a classic
vanilla custard, and that's it.
Basically, when I was looking up
custard tarts,
I found out that in the 1920s,
they used to do bone marrow
and dried fruit in the custard,
which didn't light my fire.
[Sandi] Er, the judges hopefully
won't have any bones to pick
with David's classic vanilla custard pie,
topped with on-theme
flapper girl biscuits.
I went to Matt Lucas's 30th birthday party
as a flapper girl.
-Nice.
-I've never felt so alive.
Now, if you can just punch them
in the face with flavour,
you're a shoo-in.
Well, I haven't really.
I've gone for no flavour at all.
The judges haven't come round yet,
and that's freaking me out.
There's so much going on.
It could all fall apart at any moment.
-Hello. [chuckles]
-[Paul] Right.
Tell us about your custard pies.
I'm making mango, lime and ginger,
so there's mango and lime in the custard,
and then there's ginger in the pastry.
Well, from the smell of it, there's a lot
of ginger in there. [chuckles]
Yeah. [chuckles]
[Noel] Michael is complementing
these flavours with mango gelée discs
and a decoration of meringue kisses,
white chocolate soil,
piped dark chocolate ganache,
ginger honeycomb and sugared lime peel.
-Wow, is there room?
-How big's the tart?
It's 15 centimetres wide.
Wow, that's not very big to fit all--
No, but they're all quite small.
They're all quite little bits.
[Paul] Okay, then.
Look forward to this one.
Thank you. I hope it works. [chuckles]
-Well done.
-[Michael] Thank you.
[Sandi] Michael may have
given himself a lot to do,
but one of the bakers is doing
twice as much work as everyone else.
[Priya] I'm making two custards,
a lemon custard and a raspberry custard.
The raspberry's quite sweet
and the lemon's sharp but creamy.
[Sandi] Priya's custards will be decorated
with meringue shapes and piped chocolate
and sit within a lemon shortcrust.
[Priya] All right,
I'm taking my pastry out.
My heart is racing,
there's so much going on.
I don't know how long we have left.
Bakers, you've got half an hour left...
until I cut all your fringes.
Pray for me.
[Sandi] For the perfect balance
of custard to pastry,
the pie should be filled to the brim.
[Michael] I don't like a very deep tart.
I like a shallow tart. [chuckles]
[Helena] I'm just being very careful
'cause I'm so clumsy.
[Sandi] But now they're so full,
there is a danger of any spilled custard
burning around the edges,
so they need to be moved
with extreme caution.
[Steph] Oh, God.
Slide, slide, my pretties, slide.
Yes! Right, meringue.
[Sandi] The bakers now only have
a small window of time
to finish off their decorations.
Can we make this snappy?
I've got three minutes and...
Oh, yeah, go on.
[David] She's one of the dancing girls
from Bugsy Malone.
I'm just adding the suckers
onto the tentacles.
[chuckles]
I almost said "testicles".
-What are you doing?
-[Rosie] Erm, I'm injecting jelly.
Is that how you put the horses to sleep?
-[Rosie] This is a horse needle.
-[Noel] Oh, it is?
Is it... It's quite long.
Which animals are the most difficult?
[Rosie] I find rabbits the most difficult.
-Rabbits?
-They just wanna die.
They just... [laughs]
That shouldn't be funny, but it is.
Rabbits are not my thing.
Give me an angry stallion
or a snake any day.
Or a crab with herpes. [laughs]
Yeah, herpes.
There's your out line, see you later.
They get chlamydia, not herpes, anyway.
This is the mirror glaze
which is gonna go on top of the mousse
which is setting in the freezer.
Oh, classic Henry, loves a mirror glaze.
[groans]
Neither of them have set,
the curd or the mousse.
My freezer hates me.
Going in.
[Steph] They're all right.
It's a little bit over,
but it's got a wobble to it still.
[David] My custard is not baked.
[Michelle] I just want a thin layer
so I can blowtorch it.
It's gonna be very quick decoration.
[Michelle] How long have we got left?
Bakers, you have ten minutes left.
Crunch time.
Need to get them out of the tins.
I mustn't stress or I'm gonna drop them.
I'm just being very careful
'cause I'm so clumsy.
[David] I'm just gonna go with that.
[Rosie] This is not fun. [chuckles]
The moving bit is not fun.
Oh.
Oh, no. She's dropped her tart.
I can't really
salvage that. [chuckles]
-[Henry groans]
-[Rosie] Henry, don't...
Let's get it off the floor, anyway.
Oh, darling.
-[Michael] What's happened?
-[Henry chuckles] Don't turn around.
-[Michael] Are you okay?
-[Henry] That's crushing.
[sniffs]
[sighs] I'm going home.
Bakers, you have five minutes left.
[Alice] Feeling the pressure now.
[Michelle] Oh, my days.
What I'm doing now is decoration
that can be thrown on
when I have one minute left.
[Helena] I'm almost there.
[Henry] Coming out quite cloudy, isn't it?
[Michael] Yeah, it's looking good.
Will the entire jelly melt?
That is the question.
-[Sandi] Bakers...
-You have one minute left.
Sixty seconds.
[David] It's been quite stressful,
this one.
Kind of just, er, making it up
as I go along, to be honest.
[exhales]
[Michelle] God, I can't get it off.
[Rosie] That jelly is melting.
Everything is just going wrong
in the world right now.
Bakers, your time is up.
[Sandi] Please place your custard pies
at the end of your benches.
[Rosie] I don't think
there's the possibility of
anything going any worse
in my life right now.
[Noel] It's judgment time
for the bakers' signature custard pies.
It looks like a custard pie
you'd see in a French patisserie shop.
[Noel] Yeah.
Very professional,
very neat on the outside.
It is absolutely exquisite.
You've managed to make these
flapper girls look quite flirty. [laughs]
[Paul] The base
to the amount of custard, perfect.
Beautifully cooked.
[Prue] Just cooked.
That's a custard pie.
It's silky-smooth. Delicious.
Yes.
Yeah!
[all applauding]
It's a perfect custard pie.
The base, crumbly, crispy.
The custard baked to perfection.
Beautifully level, filled to the top.
And then the design, impeccable.
Wonderful, David.
Thank you.
I like the decoration.
I think the decoration is very good.
It's not full enough.
You could've had more filling in there.
[Prue] That custard texture looks perfect.
[Paul] It looks lovely and silky.
The balance with the ginger is perfect.
It's baked beautifully.
If you'd had more custard in there,
and a little bit neater on the top,
you're looking at perfection.
-It's a beautiful pie.
-Wow.
-Well done. Thank you.
-[Michael] Thank you.
[exhales]
[Paul] Oh, dear.
What happened with the decoration?
Well, surprise, surprise,
I ran out of time.
[Prue] You could have had
a little more custard in there.
[Priya] Yes.
[Paul] You've boiled it, basically.
And so what's happened is it's bubbled up.
And as you brought it out...
-You bring it out, and then it sinks.
-[Priya] Yeah.
It tastes amazing.
Problem is, you boiled your custard,
and your pastry's too thick.
-Yeah.
-[Paul] Far too thick.
-Is there booze in there?
-[Alice] No.
Erm, so, orange juice, orange zest,
and a bit of orange extract as well.
Celebrate the orange with the zest,
not with an extract.
For me, the flavour has been overwhelmed
by that extract.
Okay.
The decoration, it's simplistic
but quite effective.
-The colour of it looks good.
-[Steph] Okay.
[Paul] It looks like the perfect colour.
It's golden.
[Prue] And I think the custard looks
beautifully set.
[Paul] The flavour's beautiful.
The pastry is fantastic as well,
'cause it's flaky.
It's delicious because
you've got lots and lots of citrus.
Okay.
Are you getting the blueberry?
I've just had a mouthful of blueberry
and didn't get anything.
I don't think blueberries have much taste.
-[Paul] It's a shame.
-Okay.
The sugar top hasn't quite worked
like a crème brûlée.
But nice idea,
and they do look very neat though.
-Thank you.
-[Paul] Erm, they look quite neat.
-[Henry] Mm-hmm.
It's very thick, that base.
Yeah, there's more base
than there is filling.
Yeah.
[Paul] Your flavour of the custard's good.
There's a lovely zing of...
-Of zest.
-The flavour's okay?
It's good. It's overbaked
because there's so little of it.
This is Helena all over, isn't it?
[laughs] It's amazing.
[Paul] I think the design is incredible.
[Noel] What a colour.
It's got lavender, so I thought
I could get away with purple.
-That is so much. Too much lavender.
-[Helena] Oh, really?
-It's a little bit soapy.
-Okay.
It's not bad.
It's not brilliant, but it's not bad.
Well, I'll take that, Paul.
I did have an accident.
-[Paul] You've lost one of them.
-Yeah.
-It's down there. You can...
-[all chuckling]
[Noel] These are incredible.
Yeah, they're absolutely exquisite,
the jelly that you've injected.
Was the plan that these
would have looked like that on top?
[Rosie] Yeah, they were on top.
And they melted. [chuckles]
[Paul] It looks a bit sad on the top
'cause it's not finished.
Pastry's quite damp. It isn't crisp.
The matcha sort of does come through.
It's not one of my favourite flavours,
matcha, but, erm...
Fair enough.
[Paul] I love the blackberry.
I love that flavour.
Flavour of the custard is delicious.
Thank you.
I am never making a custard pie again, no.
I despise pastry. I despise custard.
That could have gone better.
The pastry, Paul said it was thick.
It felt thick when I was rolling it out,
But I thought,
"I haven't got time to roll it thinner."
Should have done that.
Yeah!
I got a handshake.
1920s has been all right so far,
but there's still two challenges.
The Technical will be a disaster.
Just always is. [chuckles]
[Noel] With only mystery ingredients
and a deep fat fryer as a hint,
the bakers can only guess
what fate awaits them
in the Technical Challenge.
All right, my lovely bakers,
time for your Technical Challenge,
which today has been set for you
by Prue. Any words of advice?
Yes. There are four basic skills
needed for this challenge,
but you need to get them all right.
Now, as ever,
this challenge will be judged blind,
so we're gonna have to ask
you two lovelies to leave the tent.
Off you pop.
What are they up to today?
I think they've gone fracking.
Okay, I need to have a chat with them.
Right. Today, Prue would like you to make
18 beignets soufflés.
What's that?
-Noel.
-I've got nothing.
Okay, basically, it's a fried choux ball
filled with a smooth raspberry jam.
It needs to be crispy on the outside,
and light and fluffy on the inside.
I'm imagining they need to be uniform
in size and shape.
Yep. Served with... a sabayon.
-[Noel] Sabayon.
-[Sandi] Yeah.
-Exactly.
-Yeah.
-I mean, what is a...
-Soufflé.
-...without a...
-Sabayon?
Okay, you've got an hour and a half.
-On your marks...
-Get set...
Bake.
[groans]
[Michelle] I have never heard of it
in my life.
I don't know what it is.
I assume it's like profiteroles, kind of.
There's literally six instructions.
Your guess is as good as mine, mate.
Prue, beignets soufflés.
[Prue] It is 1920s week,
and these were very popular then.
They should all know how to make
choux pastry,
so that shouldn't be
too much of a problem.
[Paul] I reckon most of them wouldn't have
fried choux pastry before.
-Because you usually bake choux.
-[Paul] You normally bake choux.
But the most difficult thing is
how are you going to get it into
perfect balls and drop it in the fat?
I think the best way to do it
is to do it with two spoons.
-The quenelle.
-Yeah, but try and get it round
rather than quenelle-shaped.
[Paul] So, what do we expect to see
inside this?
[Prue] Lots of air, and some soft,
almost stretchy dough.
Just wanna see what it's like
with the sabayon as well.
[Paul] They're delicious, and the jam
gives that nice richness to it.
Nice and smooth,
and the sabayon, it's like a little cloud
which carries
a little bit of flavour to it as well.
I just hope we get some fantastic, light,
airy beignets soufflés in the tent.
With a perfect sabayon.
-Not much to ask, is it?
-[chuckles]
"For the beignets batter,
make pâte à choux."
What the hell is a "pâte à choux"?
Well, I assume it's choux pastry.
[Michael] Choux pastry,
I made once upon a time,
but I've kind of forgotten everything.
[David] I think I might just
literally chuck everything in
and see what happens.
We've got all the measurements,
it's just how they go in.
I'm melting the butter in the water,
'cause I feel like that's right.
And then I'm getting ready
to shoot the flour in and beat a lot.
Not entirely sure
why I need to shoot it in,
but I remember hearing that.
[Henry] From what I remember with choux,
I've got to cook off the moisture
and this should come cleanly away
from the side of the pan.
This looks fine,
but I know I've got to add the eggs.
But I'm concerned if I put them in now,
will they scramble?
But I don't know when to put them in.
[Michael] Not while it's hot,
'cause that'll cook the eggs.
Maybe it needs to cook the eggs. I just...
[Henry] I'm adding the egg bit by bit.
I don't wanna shock it
or add all the moisture in one go.
How happy was your face?
Beignets soufflés, sabayon.
Keep doing the smiley face.
Oh, what? Really?
Well, it's just not, like,
looking like a choux should look.
Okay. What should it look like?
It should drop.
And it's so...
I mean, it's dropping,
but it's not dropping nicely.
[Helena] I think this is
what it's meant to look like.
It's pipeable, but it's, like...
It's runny.
A little bit more in.
Let's see what that does.
[David] I might just
take it off the heat now.
Maybe let it sit for a bit?
I have no idea.
Okay. "Three. Working in batches
and piping directly onto
an oiled dessert spoon,
pipe 18 round balls of choux
and carefully drop into the oil and fry."
Obvious.
Deep fat fryer on 190.
I'm gonna try and pipe my choux
and just hope for the best,
but this feels quite runny.
[David] This looks lovely, doesn't it?
[Michelle] How the hell
do you make a ball out of them?
I'm just gonna put a bit of dough in.
Let's go.
It's gone straight to the bottom.
[David] Come on, float, float, float.
Blow up, get crispy and float.
Ooh. I mean, it's puffed
into something, hasn't it?
[Steph] Why won't it flip over?
-Is that really hot, that fat?
-[Rosie] Oh!
-Watch your face.
-It's 190 degrees.
This could be like a Face/Off thing.
Have you seen that film?
Where our faces get burnt
and we have to swap our faces.
And I have to become a vet
and you have to go and do stand-up.
How would you feel about that?
I think your audiences will be
a little disappointed.
I think there are some angry stallions
getting pretty riled as I put
the wrong hands up their bums.
The wrong hands?
How can you put the wrong hands?
Oh, is it either hand?
-Surely if the horse--
-You've gotta be an ambidextrous rectaler.
That could be a ball, you know?
I don't know how people are making balls.
This needs to be round.
Almost wanna, like, cut one open and
just see what the hell is going on inside.
What's it meant to be like again?
Crisp on the outside, soft on the inside.
That's disgusting.
It's totally raw in the middle.
[Michael] I'm gonna remake the choux,
to make it stiffer.
Maybe I didn't whisk it enough.
Hmm. Interesting.
-[Sandi] Time for a time call.
-I've got this.
-Don't worry.
-Halfway through.
Bakers, you are halfway through!
Halfway through!
Even without batteries,
these are working brilliantly.
[Michael] I'm gonna make
the choux pastry again.
It needs to be stiffer,
but I don't know how.
[David] I'm starting my pastry again.
The problem is that
I don't know how to make choux.
That's the basic problem.
How many am I meant to make, 18?
[Steph] I seem to be getting
a technique here.
The choux is just not stiff enough
to pipe.
See, it's runny again.
This is embarrassing.
Second batch looks the same
as the first one.
That one looks like a round one.
The rest don't.
[Alice] Mine are burnt.
[Michael] It's too soft.
I know it's too soft.
See, it just doesn't hold together.
At this point, I don't think
I'm gonna have anything to present.
-Michael, you okay?
-[Michael] I'm freaking out.
I'm finding it really hard.
Keep going. Keep going, Michael.
[breathing heavily]
[whispering] Come on, come on, come on.
Please, please, please.
[breathing heavily]
Bakers, you have half an hour left,
half an hour.
[whispering] I can't...
I can't do it anymore.
[Henry] These aren't looking too shabby.
They're deflating now.
I don't think I can do this anymore.
Why don't you get those two out,
have a little quick walk for five minutes,
then come back?
No, I need to keep going. [sniffles]
Otherwise I'll stop.
[Noel] You're doing really well.
You're good at this.
-[chuckling]
-Imagine me doing this. I've got nothing.
[Michael sniffles]
We're nearly there.
You can do this.
I'm happy with the balls.
Better than David's, that's for sure.
They look like Scotch eggs.
[Henry] ...11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16... 18.
We've got 18 things.
I'm wondering
whether to get the jam on.
Nothing on the instructions,
just "make a jam".
I'm gonna chuck in the berries
and the sugar together.
I've not stopped...
and that's really good.
Anything at this point, I've won.
[Priya] I'm getting there.
Okay, jam is looking jammy.
We're going pips out
'cause we were asked for smooth jam.
So, I'm making jam. Let's see
if I can get something to present.
-[Sandi] Bakers...
-You have 15 minutes left!
I'm gonna make the sabayon.
What is a sabayon?
I'm gonna assume a sabayon is a custard.
"Caster sugar, egg yolks,
-and... marsala."
-Ooh!
I'm thinking whisk the egg and sugar
over a bain-marie.
[Henry] It's raw egg yolks,
so I've got to somehow cook it.
This might be
the best way to do it.
I'm guessing it's gotta be
quite thick to dip in.
I am gonna get this to ribbon stage,
and then I'll put some of this in.
I don't know if this is done,
or what it's meant to be like.
This is not a sabayon.
[Helena] Let's try it.
It's looking nice and thick.
Oh! That's all right. [chuckles]
-How long's left?
-You have five minutes left.
I need to pipe jam into these bad boys.
I can do anything for five minutes.
Don't wanna go too much
because probably haven't got enough.
I can't fit any jam in this
'cause it's solid.
I have to scoop some stuff out of it.
They're deflated,
but at least it's something.
Okay, I'm gonna pick my 18.
-Can you count them for me?
-[Noel] Yeah.
One, two, three, four, five, six...
[Helena] ...16, 17... It's 18, isn't it?
-You've got 14 there.
-Thank you.
-[Helena] Then it's the sabayon.
-[Priya] I need every bit of this.
Sprinkle with icing sugar.
[Alice] They look appalling.
Last one, 18.
[whispers] Come on.
Bakers, your time is up.
I have finished, that's for sure.
Right, everybody,
up to the table, please.
Bring your beignets soufflés
and place them behind your photograph.
[Noel] Prue and Paul are looking for
18 perfectly-formed beignets soufflés,
filled with raspberry jam,
and served alongside a beautiful sabayon.
-Shall we start at that end?
-Absolutely.
[Prue] They look good, the balls.
[Paul] They're all fairly round,
and they look fairly light.
-Not a bad filling.
-[Prue] No.
-[Paul] The structure's there.
-[Prue] Yes.
-Tastes good.
-[Prue] Mm.
That is a very interesting sauce,
but it's not what we asked for.
[Paul] These are interesting.
They look like potatoes.
-The colour's not bad.
-Yeah, the colour's okay.
[Prue] Very good jam,
but too doughy inside.
-How's the sabayon?
-It's got the flavour of it.
It's not quite there on the texture.
It needs to be much fluffier.
Moving on. Now these, way too dark.
[Prue] They're fairly even.
[Paul] The texture inside is pretty good.
Mmm. They're nice and light.
[Paul] The sabayon's split as well.
Now moving on.
I've got a few issues.
-They're more like blinis, aren't they?
-[Prue] Yeah.
There's no volume in the choux.
Although, the sabayon...
[Prue] Looks very, very good.
-Taste good?
-Yeah, it is good.
These are round, aren't they?
And their colour's not bad,
it's a little dark.
They are cooked inside,
though, these beignets.
A little bit too much jam.
But they taste okay, and they are baked
all the way through.
Unfortunately, the sabayon
is just not whisked enough.
[Paul] Yeah. It's split really badly.
These beignets, you've gone
from the sublime to the ridiculous.
Mm. I wouldn't call that sublime,
-but it's...
-[Paul] But it's sublime-ish...
[both] ...compared to that.
[Paul] They seem all baked through.
Yeah.
[Prue] Too much jam.
-[Paul] The sabayon's flavour's okay.
-[Prue] Right. This is not a happy sight.
[Paul] It's like a churros
-that hasn't opened up slightly.
-[Prue chuckles] Yes.
-[Paul] They're raw inside.
-[Prue] Yeah.
[Paul] And that is not a sabayon.
Now these don't look too bad.
[both] They're a nice colour.
I hope, when you cut into it,
that we see a nice aeration inside,
which we do.
[Prue] Not too much jam.
[crunching]
[Paul] They're delicious.
Mmm. They are good.
The sabayon's not good.
Sabayon's split.
Yeah, it's a bit thin.
Moving on to the last one.
A variety of different colours here.
-These are all cooked inside.
-[Prue] They look really nicely done.
[Paul] The structure's good.
It's just a pity that they are so uneven.
[Paul] That's very thick and very dark.
It's like a cream, isn't it?
[Sandi] Prue and Paul will now rank
the beignets soufflés from worst to best.
Right, bakers.
Well, in ninth place, we have this one.
[imitates dramatic fanfare]
-Sorry.
-[Prue] David.
Well, it was a fair old disaster.
-Yeah.
-[Prue] Wrong shape,
raw in the middle, not good.
In eight spot, we have this one.
Whose is this?
Burnt and raw.
[Sandi] Michelle is seventh,
Alice sixth,
Rosie fifth,
Steph fourth,
and Henry's in third.
And in second place is... this one.
-Whose is this?
-Mine.
-[all chuckling]
-These are not bad at all.
I don't know what happened
with your sabayon.
Which means that in first place...
[all cheering]
[laughter]
Your actual beignets were perfect.
The structure and jam was lovely,
but you did split your sabayon.
So, you only just scraped into top place.
-I'm taking it, Prue. I don't care.
-[all laughing]
Can you believe it? Oh, my God.
Bless all the bakers.
They genuinely wanted me to win it,
'cause I've struggled every week
with the Technical.
Screw the handshake,
I want a hug, please.
After such a high in the morning
and having a really good Signature,
it is a shame to have done
so badly in the Technical.
I could've gone to have a walk,
but I knew that I wouldn't come back.
So, I'm not bothered about
coming eighth out of nine
because I still managed to make them.
Yay!
That's enough.
[Noel] Just the Showstopper Challenge
remains,
before we discover who'll be Star Baker...
[Michael] Good luck.
...and who will be leaving the tent.
Have you ever seen
such a flip-flop as we've had?
-It has been extraordinary.
-With David?
-Is that a term, "flip-flopping"?
-It is, flip-flopping, yeah.
So, David, first of all,
amazing, handshake, Signature.
Fantastic,
and then ninth in the Technical.
But then also,
if you get somebody like Helena
who didn't do so well
in the Signature,
and then first in the Technical.
I really fear for Priya.
She has to do something amazing
in the Showstopper.
She didn't do very well in her Signature.
The whole thing had sunk.
She boiled it basically.
I'm not a baker, but the way you say,
"She boiled it,"
I imagine that's not a good thing.
-[all laughing]
-No.
I think ultimately,
this challenge is gonna be
the maker or breaker of people.
[Prue] We were worried about
Michael being so emotional,
but he shouldn't be so worried.
-He's doing all right.
-Yeah.
What's all this emotion?
I'm missing this, obviously.
-You've never had emotions.
-Darling...
It's not your area. [laughs]
...you steely alpha male.
You're like a Marine,
you've never had an emotion.
[Sandi laughing]
Do you get a funny feeling
in your tummy when you like someone?
A sort of tingle?
-I thought that was a curry.
-[all laughing]
Hello, bakers. Welcome back to the tent.
Now, continuing our celebration
of the Roaring Twenties,
you'll be making a Prohibition-era cake.
Prohibition was the time
when alcohol was banned in America.
It was sold only by gangsters,
like Al Capone.
Just think of yourselves as Al Capone,
but in an apron,
-with no Mafia connections.
-Thank you, Noel.
Basically, Paul and Prue would like
you to make a 1920s-themed two-tier cake.
Your flavour should be
based on your favourite cocktail,
and the design should be
a visual spectacle of the era.
Bring back
the Roaring Twenties cocktail culture.
-You have four hours.
-On your marks...
-Get set...
-Bake.
Eggs.
It's gone quiet.
I hate the quiet.
-[Helena] I love it.
-[Henry scoffs]
-That's surprising from you, Helena.
-Yeah.
We've given them four hours
to produce this Prohibition cake.
So, you've gotta think backwards.
How long will it take
to decorate the cake?
Allow yourself at least an hour,
maybe more.
Your sponges should be in and out
of the oven within the hour,
and that gives you plenty of time
to produce real baking magic.
I want three things.
I want wonderful design,
a delicious cake,
and it will taste
of a recognisable cocktail.
I need to get the hashtag RealMenCry
trending this year.
-[laughs]
-Hashtag-ManTears.
[Noel] For their sponge tiers,
the bakers must choose flavours
that celebrate their chosen cocktails.
I'm putting a bit of coconut extract in
to make sure that it's quite coconutty.
Coffee liqueur, vodka...
chocolate caramel and cream
is the cocktail.
What is not to love about that?
[Noel] Most of the bakers
will be introducing alcohol
in the form of a drizzle,
which cannot be added
until the sponges are baked.
Once this cake's in the oven,
and once it's out of the oven,
I'll feel a lot better.
-[Paul] Hi, Michael.
-Good morning.
Tell us all about your Prohibition cake.
It's based on a Bramble,
which is gin and lemon
with a blackberry syrup
that trickles through it.
When you cut into it, hopefully...
I shouldn't say this
because you'll look for it now.
But I'm hoping
-that you'll see in the layers...
-Careful.
...the syrup trickling through the sponge
like in a Bramble.
[Sandi] Michael will also be replicating
the Bramble cocktail
around his drizzled sponge
with an ombré-effect buttercream coating.
Trying to go simple
and elegant '20s, erm...
Whether I achieve that or not,
we'll discover in about three hours...
and 43 minutes.
[Sandi] As Michael counts down
the time, true to form,
Helena has a far more
ghoulish count in mind.
The inspiration for the cake is based on
Bram Stoker's first adaptation of Dracula.
-Nosferatu.
-That's right.
And that was in 1922.
So, the sponge is red velvet
'cause I'm thinking blood.
[Noel laughing]
Hold on one second,
I just need to get the fly off you.
They come to me 'cause I'm dead.
[laughing]
[Sandi] Helena's dead--
Sorry, red velvet sponge
will be soaked
in a homemade raspberry vodka.
Isomalt bat-wings will protrude
from the top of her cake
above white-chocolate fangs
inspired by her cocktail of choice,
a Vampire's Kiss.
Is a Vampire's Kiss a real cocktail,
or did you make it up?
It is a real cocktail.
-Have you had a Vampire's Kiss?
-Don't wanna talk about it.
-[all laughing]
-It's between me and Noel.
Right, just need to get these in.
My oven's at 180. I'm gonna
put them in for about 25 minutes.
[Noel] With multiple sponges
in varying sizes,
the bakers now face an epic test
of their ability to multitask.
They will take different times to bake
because there's three different sizes.
I've got so much to do.
While this is cooking,
I'll make my curd.
[Noel] The fillings give the bakers
another opportunity
to supercharge their cocktail flavours.
I'm adding the booze.
I hope they like coconut rum.
Just making the raspberry coulis
and we're gonna put
raspberry liqueur in there.
[Sandi] I wish to discuss with you
your progress.
So, yesterday...
Let's re-enact for ourselves,
a handshake.
Excellent.
Now, let's think about the Technical.
It looked like something
the dog had done.
-Hero to zero, literally.
-It was a weird technical, wasn't it?
-Was it?
-Wasn't it?
Yours was the only one that looked like
the dog had done it.
[both laughing]
Yeah.
I don't know if you're optimistic today
or miserable.
-I'm optimistic.
-Yes!
[Noel] David is confident
his highly-decorated cake
will contain the correct amount
of amaretto and aromatic bitters
to represent his chosen cocktail,
an Amaretto Sour.
[David] I've still not actually
had one yet.
I don't really drink.
Every now and again, I would have
a glass of prosecco at a wedding,
but I'm not really
an alcohol drinker, no.
[Sandi] Someone who's a little bolder
when a wedding is involved is Michelle.
We went to Liverpool
for my sister's hen do.
Oh, my God, that was some crazy weekend.
And we drunk copious amounts of cocktails.
So, I've actually made this cake
for my sister.
[Sandi] Michelle is recreating
the classic flavours of a piña colada
by layering her coconut sponge
with a pineapple filling.
The bottom tier's rum buttercream textures
are inspired by impressionist painters,
whereas the top tier will feature
a more up-to-date geode-effect fault line.
-I love piña colada.
-[Prue] I do, too.
Coconut and pineapple
are a marriage made in heaven.
[Sandi] It seems Michelle isn't
the only baker pursuing a tropical taste.
Mine is inspired by, erm, piña colada.
This is the Swiss meringue buttercream.
The flavour is coming from a white rum.
I think there's like
four piña colada cakes.
Er, yeah.
We, er... We didn't get the memo
not to do the same thing.
[Sandi] Alice's interpretation will have
pineapple and rum sponges
sandwiched with coconut buttercream
and a rum pineapple filling,
giving a classic
pineapple upside-down cake
a piña colada twist.
I was doing my research
and I found out
that pineapple upside-down cakes
-were a massive thing in the '20s.
-Is that right, Prue?
In the 1920s, when you were dining out
around that time, did you--
[laughing]
He's so rude.
I like the idea
of a pineapple upside-down cake
'cause there's a few people doing
these piña colada cakes.
-This is a different way of doing it.
-Yeah.
It's just a really popular drink.
You've gotta be the best
out of the piña colada gang.
Ooh, pressure.
[Sandi] One of the bakers 1920s research
has seen her raiding the pantry.
Apparently, tinned goods were
all the rage in the 1920s,
flavours like pineapple
and pineapple upside-down cake.
Erm, yeah.
So, yeah, we're using the tradition.
But the point is that apparently
you can get a considerably better curd
with canned pineapple juice.
[Sandi] Steph's curd will sandwich
alternating lime and coconut sponges
inspired by a family holiday
in the Caribbean.
I remember us all sat on a sunbed
in the sea drinking piña colada.
I think it was one of those
all-inclusive hotels
where they probably water it down
quite a lot, but it was good.
The little ones can probably come out.
I'm not expecting the big ones
to be done yet.
That should be fine.
This is the top tier.
The big cake is in the oven,
but I need to get other stuff done
in the meantime.
So getting my coffee liqueur syrup made.
This is the strongest coffee
I could find in the world.
Well, in Waitrose.
[Noel] Henry will be using his coffee
throughout his white Russian cake
in a coffee sponge
drizzled with coffee liqueur.
His three tiers will then be coated
in Italian meringue coffee buttercream,
and decorated
with chocolate geometric shapes.
This looks good, this bit here.
If it looks anything like this,
I'll be so happy, honestly.
Right, bloody calm down.
Flip these cakes over and let's go.
I'm not dropping anything today.
There are enough ways I can mess it up
without throwing things on the floor.
[Sandi] Rosie is coating
her coffee liqueur sponges
with a chocolate ganache before decorating
with a mirror glaze, pulled sugar feathers
and piped gold royal icing.
Rosie, this is an amazing lot to do.
-I just hope you pull it off.
-I blooming need to.
-You do need to.
-[Paul] Good luck.
-Thank you, Rosie.
-[Rosie] Thank you.
I think that's code for "better be
bloody brilliant or you're out."
Sandi, we're gonna have a sack race.
Basically, you're in the sack
and I'll just be using my own legs.
Actually I'll give you a head-start.
Bakers, you're halfway through.
[sputters]
[Henry] They're done.
That's all cake done now.
[Rosie] This is my caramel
and coffee liqueur syrup.
I'm trying not to make the cakes
too wet with it,
just brushing on enough
to add a bit more flavour.
[Sandi] A heavy hand at this stage
could result in a soggy, unstable sponge.
[David] Going a bit liberal
with the amaretto.
It's a bit of a nightmare
even you're doing a cocktail cake
and they can't even taste the alcohol.
[Sandi] But not enough alcohol
runs the risk of the cake
being dry and flavourless.
There's a bit of booze,
but it's not very boozy.
I'm not looking for a boozy flavour
in my cake.
[Sandi] Ooh, loving the colour.
It's, erm, vampire-inspired.
-Oh, really? No.
-Yeah.
I made my own raspberry vodka.
-Do you wanna try? Give it a sip.
-Okay. Let's just give this a go.
How much do we love this stopper?
Sandi, you actually...
Go for it, go for it.
[coughs]
[wheezing]
Okay, I'm just gonna lie
in a dark room for a bit
-and I'll be right back. Whoo!
-Okay, fine.
[Noel] The only baker abstaining
from the demon drink is Priya.
[Priya] I'm coating it
with a passion fruit syrup.
Mine's a proper Prohibition cake
'cause it has no alcohol in it.
[Noel] The fourth member
of the piña colada gang
is sandwiching passion-fruit sponges
with coconut buttercream
and pineapple curd
in an alcohol-free mocktail cake.
If Priya doesn't have
a really strong Showstopper,
Priya may not be here next week.
So, yeah, I kinda wanna be here.
It's nice.
Bakers, you have one hour left.
One hour!
[Sandi] Assembling their
multi-tiered cakes quickly is crucial...
This is so time-consuming.
[Sandi] ...if the bakers
are to leave enough time
for their all-important decoration.
[Alice] Don't want to be shoving
decoration on with a minute to go.
I would love to just spend my time
decorating it nicely.
It is a dark-chocolate ganache,
slightly thicker than I wanted.
[David] All my cakes
have slightly sunk in the middle.
Are you gonna be all right for time?
At home, I'm generally really quick
'cause I have to be.
-'Cause you've got kids.
-Kids.
Are you gonna let them
watch this on telly?
Yeah, I will. They'll find it really odd.
They'll think you've been kidnapped.
"Mum, why has that vampire kidnapped you?"
-"What's happening? Who is this?"
-And that Ewok.
"Who's that guy?
"And that angry polar bear?
And that glamorous posh lady?"
I must say, I think there are
no flavours here that I fear.
Seems to be four different
techniques of making a piña colada cake,
so that's gonna be interesting.
It's a question of
who's going to do the best bake,
and who's going to do
the most interesting 1920s design.
It's all down to this Showstopper.
This is probably gonna be the one,
the challenge. I want them all to do well,
and then we can judge it from there.
Which will make it difficult.
-Fairy cake.
-Oh, you're too good at this game.
Bakers, you've got half an hour left.
Half an hour!
I'm-- I'm really scared to move it.
Like, really scared.
I've gotta put that on there and I just
don't know how stable it is at the moment.
Whoa. Fuck, that was close.
[exhales sharply]
That's so near the edge.
Oh, Christ.
It's a mess.
At the moment, I feel like the fear
is making me very... ooh, sloppy.
[Sandi] With their tiers
safely assembled...
-I've got a cake.
-...decoration can now begin in earnest.
-[Priya exhales] This is a hot job.
-[Michelle] God, I've got such a sweat on.
[Alice] It's so hot in here.
Buttercream is melting.
[Helena] I'm shaking.
-You seem very calm.
-Yeah, well...
Don't really get flustered, do you?
You know it's gonna be fine.
And if they're not,
then you can't change it, can you?
-Wow. You're like the Dalai Lama.
-[laughs]
You need to chat to Michael. Bless him.
Is he all right today?
[David] He's very quiet today.
He's silenced the screaming
in his mind with gin.
-That's what I do.
-Yeah. Definitely.
This is the first tiered cake
I've made in my life.
And possibly the last.
-[Sandi] Bakers...
-[Noel] You have...
-Ten minutes...
-Left.
[sighs heavily]
I feel some pressure in this
'cause it's about decoration.
It has to look spectacular.
I've done it better than this
but I'm happy that I'm getting there.
I'm just gonna, like, remind myself
I do actually enjoy this.
It's melting.
-These are just, like, falling down.
-[Steph] Henry, do you need any help?
I'm having triangular misbehaviour
over here.
-Do you want me to move these?
-Could you? This is...
I want a place reserved in heaven for you.
You know I like decoration.
[Priya] It's stained glass
so it's supposed to be a bit rough.
I'm just doing extra things now.
Any chance I might have had
of surviving is gone.
Your time is up. Place your Showstoppers
at the end of your benches.
Okay, done.
I think less is more, isn't it?
Yours looks beautiful. Like, really cool.
Why the hell did I do that?
It's time for the Prohibition Era cakes
to face the judgment of Paul and Prue.
I must say, Michael, it's really neat.
It's original. Nicely done.
And it's stark because
you've got the blackberries
with the black icing. It's really unusual.
Your piping's really good.
It's pretty accurate.
[exhales sharply]
I know you had this idea that
you'd have the drizzle running down
-like you do in the drink.
-Yeah.
It sort of hasn't worked.
It looks like a smudge.
I like the lemon. The sponge is good.
But I'd have loved to have
that fruit coming through,
that sharpness coming through.
You may have got the colour,
but you certainly haven't got the flavour.
-Okay.
-Nice cake, though.
Thank you.
You know, it's such a mixture
-of sinister and very pretty.
-[laughing]
That's me. [laughing]
I don't like the outside of it,
and I tell you why.
-Why?
-The piping work is not good.
Okay, let's have a look inside.
-That's a red cake.
-[laughs] It is.
-It's a bit bland inside.
-Bland?
-Yeah. It's quite dry.
-[Prue] You get the vodka.
You don't get much raspberry.
But I find it a pleasant cake.
If you shut your eyes,
it's a nice sponge cake.
Thanks, Prue. [chuckles]
-It's quite an elegant-looking cake.
-It looks really dramatic.
And very '20s. I like that.
Lovely flavour. Really good flavour.
-I think it's a little dry.
-[Henry] Mm-hmm.
-Yes, it's a bit dry.
-Okay.
But the design, structure,
and flavour is very good.
Thank you.
That's one of the most interesting
looking cakes I've seen for a long time.
That took a bit of getting through.
It's the ganache. I wanted it really firm
so I could crumb coat it.
Wow. Wow.
That's not a ganache,
that's a bar of chocolate.
I can certainly taste the alcohol.
I like the sponge inside.
The flavours are beautiful.
My biggest complaint is the thickness
of the outside of the cake.
-Okay.
-I think it's a really good cake,
but you know it's not perfect.
Yeah.
I like the sort of naked cake look.
Are they meant to be
dropped into each other?
-No.
-[Prue laughs]
-Could have got away with that, David.
-I know. Definitely weren't.
Mmm, it's fine. Nice and lemony.
-Good strong flavour.
-The buttercream's quite grainy.
And I don't like that in a buttercream.
It should be absolutely silky-smooth.
But the sponge is baked well
and I like the lemon.
Close up, it does look a bit of a mess.
I think the drawing on here is not good.
It could be a lot neater than that.
There's some really big
pieces of pineapple in here.
The flavour's nice, I just think
the pieces are a little bit clumsy.
It's a really good cake.
It could be fantastic.
Yeah.
I think the decoration has been rushed.
It needs to be much more vibrant.
Yeah.
It's quite a delicate flavour. Very nice.
I'd like perhaps
a little more passion fruit.
-Overall, the cake's nice.
-Yeah.
But your fondant on the outside's
a bit too thick.
Yeah.
If you're thinking of piña colada
as a cake, I think you've got one.
-Okay.
-And it tells you what's in there.
-Yeah.
-Piña colada.
-Let's see how it tastes.
-Hmm.
Wow. That just dropped through.
-Is that good or bad?
-[whispers] I don't know.
That looks really appetising.
I like the different colours.
-I love the lime sponges.
-They're delicious.
I've never had anything like it.
That's a first for me.
-And it works.
-It's really good.
Clever.
Thank you, Steph.
Michelle, I think this...
decoration, the way you've tackled it,
is really interesting,
and it's actually quite pretty.
But I think you've overthought it.
There are too many concepts.
That doesn't go with that,
-and that doesn't go with that.
-Let's have a look inside.
The sponges are nice and equal.
-They look a nice texture.
-Yeah.
You've got shavings and flakiness
of coconut in there,
-which don't work in a cake.
-Okay.
And I think that cake's slightly too dry.
You're getting a lack of flavour.
A smaller cake with
more of the pineapple in,
with none of the coconut.
You'd end up with a cake
that's slightly shorter
but full of flavour all the way through.
It couldn't get any worse, could it?
I had a roasting.
I feel like I've been told off
by teachers from school.
I mean, Prue said this morning,
"I hope you pull off, you need to."
Then she said to me, "Not perfect."
[Priya] I, so badly,
wanna stay for another week,
but might be the end of
the little dream for me. Who knows?
Every week, I've nailed the Showstopper,
it's what saved me.
This week that I don't nail it,
thankfully, I came top
on the Technical,
did okay in the Signature.
Gee, I hope that's enough.
Let's go through the top of the pack,
the ones that you really liked.
-Steph is looking good.
-Steph's looking good.
[Prue] Steph has been
a very consistent baker.
-She had a good week.
-The lime knocked you out.
Yeah. Henry...
-Henry did a decent job.
-His flavours were really good.
[Paul] I liked--
It was quite an elegant cake.
Henry normally misses that slightly.
-David's you liked?
-It was a great decoration.
Very well thought through, very artistic.
And he did back that style up
-with a little bit of substance.
-Yeah.
Who might we be saying goodbye to?
-Wow. There's quite a lot to be honest.
-There's an awful lot.
I think you're looking at Michelle,
Helena, Priya, Rosie.
But on this point, I think, when you
look over the three challenges closely,
I think there are two people
that are beginning to fall away.
Okay.
Well done, bakers, for getting
through the Roaring Twenties.
Now, fortunately,
I've got the wonderful job
of announcing the person
who's won Star Baker.
The person who's won
Star Baker this week is...
Steph.
[applauding]
Again!
So, that means I have the horrible job
of sending home, I'm afraid,
-two of you this week.
-Okay.
And the two people
who are going home are...
-Michelle and Helena. I'm so sorry.
-Oh, Helena.
Oh.
-Oh.
-Well, at least we go together.
-I'm so sorry, sweetheart.
-It's all right.
No surprise, was it? To be fair.
Oh, darling.
I'm so happy getting to week five.
I never thought I'd get here,
so to be here, to get Star Baker,
and to leave on week five, perfect.
I'm bringing the geode cake to Extra Slice
'cause I love it.
I love the fault line.
I've loved it. It's been fun.
It's been emotional. It's been emotional.
I have enjoyed it and I've made
some really good friends.
Friends for life, yes.
-What? What's happening here?
-I'm sorry we got rid of your sister.
Family. Brutal.
I'm actually okay about it.
I've had an amazing time.
I've learned that I can take criticism,
I can have a laugh with it.
And take the positives out of everything,
which hopefully I'll carry on doing.
I definitely feel like I've dodged
the biggest bullet in the world.
Cat with nine lives.
[Priya] I was ready to, like,
hold hands together and skip out.
I thought I was going.
I'd accepted it, I'd moved on,
I'd come to terms with it
and now it's like, what?
I don't understand.
Prue came and told me it was really close,
I did nearly go.
[inhales sharply] Yeah.
[giggles]
You legend, twice in a row. Wow.
Steph has been Star Baker
two weeks running.
-Erm, she doesn't know how good she is.
-Wow.
I literally feel like the person that's
always been middle-of-the-road,
erm... and it just all feels a bit weird.
Ah! I'm just so speechless.
I'm like, "What?"
Er, I just, I'm-- Yeah, lost for words.